Making a movie isn't child's play — even
for a child actor.
Throughout Hollywood history, kids in the
industry have been called upon to act in harrowing
roles that push the limits of their abilities,
and according to some critics, the boundaries
of good taste.
Here are some of the most famous examples
of underage actors in mature roles.
Dakota Fanning, Hounddog
In 2007, 12 year-old Fanning shocked critics
and viewing audiences alike by taking the
role of the neglected, abused Lewellen in
this coming-of-age drama — which includes
a scene in which her character is taken.
Though the violent act is strictly implied
with shots of Fanning's face and hands, the
film was subject to intense backlash from
viewers, critics, and activist groups who
felt that the young actress shouldn't have
been allowed to join the production.
Fanning responded to the criticism by pushing
back, saying, "It's a movie and it's called
acting.
[...] I wanted to do the film because I thought
it might help one person that has happened
to and help them overcome adversity in their
lives."
Unfortunately, Fanning's hopes of reaching
abuse survivors were effectively undermined
by the controversy, which killed the film's
buzz.
Hounddog only earned $131,000 against its
$3 million budget after a limited release.
Natalie Portman, The Professional
Seventeen years before she danced her way
to an Oscar win, Portman made her big-screen
debut in this 1993 thriller as Mathilda, a
little girl whose family is taken by a
corrupt DEA agent.
When she takes refuge with a neighbor — who
happens to be a hitman — he becomes her
mentor in all things vengeance, a relationship
tinged by an uneasy chemistry between the
two.
At twelve years old, Portman was the exact
same age as the character she was playing
— and watching her smoke, shoot, and even
hold a gun to her own head made for a shocking
spectacle, albeit one that proved she was
a star who could handle the most challenging
roles out there.
"One shot, not bad.
Huh?"
Kirsten Dunst, Interview with the Vampire
This list wouldn't be complete without this
chilling performance by Dunst, in one of her
very first feature film roles.
In Anne Rice's Vampire Chronicles, Dunst's
character Claudia was only five years old
when she was turned into a vampire — but
even for Hollywood, that would have been pushing
it.
Instead, the role went to the eleven year-old
actress, who went all-out to capture the anger,
violence, and near-insanity of an adult woman
who's trapped for eternity in the body of
a little girl.
As disturbing as it was to see Dunst tackle
the challenging material, she did do an amazing
job, earning a Golden Globe nomination and
a permanent spot on the A-list for her performance.
Christian Bale, Empire of the Sun
Long before he became famous for American
Psycho, The Machinist, or The Dark Knight
trilogy, Christian Bale won critical acclaim
for playing the role of Jim in the 1987 Steven
Spielberg war film Empire of the Sun.
The movie is essentially a coming-of-age drama
set during Japan's occupation of China during
World War II, and Bale was just thirteen when
he took on the challenging role of a boy who
goes from living a comfortable life with his
family in Shanghai to growing up behind the
barbed wire of a Japanese internment camp.
Spielberg doesn't pull any punches with Empire
of the Sun, and despite being just a child
himself, Bale delivers an emotional and commanding
performance as a boy faced with the horrors
of war.
Macaulay Culkin, The Good Son
Evil kids have been a staple of thriller and
horror movies over the years, but that didn't
stop audiences from being alarmed by the sight
of little Kevin McCallister from Home Alone
playing this cold-blooded, pint-sized psychopath
in The Good Son.
There's no supernatural element driving Henry's
penchant for mayhem.
He's just plain bad.
When his cousin Mark, played by Elijah Wood,
comes to visit Henry's family during winter
vacation, things turn decidedly dark.
It's hard to decide what's more disturbing
— watching a 12-year-old try to take everyone
that crosses him…
"Don't f--- with me"
...or trying to pretend that it wasn't hilarious
to watch this same little kid perpetrate savage
acts of violence against two bumbling criminals
in a John Hughes Christmas comedy just three
years earlier.
"Ah"
Because of the obvious Home Alone parallels,
The Good Son wasn't really scary enough to
make anyone scream… except maybe Culkin's
parents, who had to watch Macaulay very convincingly
attempt to murder his real-life little sister
Quinn in scenes like this one.
Jodie Foster, Taxi Driver
Foster stirred up quite a controversy when
she appeared as child walker Iris in Martin
Scorsese's 1976 classic Taxi Driver.
"You talkin to me?"
While not the central figure of the film,
Iris still plays an important part when her
path crosses with the troubled Travis Bickle,
played by Robert De Niro — and Foster was
just twelve when she played the role.
For that reason, Scorsese took precautions:
his young star was subjected to psych evaluations
to make sure she could handle the job, and
her older sister Connie was used as a stand-in
for suggestive scenes.
Olivia Hussey and Claire Danes, Romeo & Juliet
Shakespeare's famous play centers on a pair
of star-crossed teenage lovers — but it's
also full of sex, violence, and ending.
That means that casting actual teenagers in
the lead roles has historically raised some
eyebrows.
First came Franco Zeffirelli's 1968 adaptation,
in which actress Olivia Hussey was only 15,
and her Romeo, Leonard Whiting, was 17.
Thirty years later, director Baz Luhrmann
went with an older Romeo in the form of Leonardo
DiCaprio, who was 21 at the time.
But Claire Danes, who played Juliet, was just
16 — which made her two years older than
her character, but in some folks' opinions,
still much too young to be playing a scene
like this onscreen.
Jacob Reynolds, Gummo
Not many entries on this list can top 1997's
experimental dystopian art film Gummo when
it comes to making audiences squirm.
Written and directed by Harmony Korine, Gummo
chronicles the lives of several residents
of Xenia, Ohio, following the effects of a
devastating tornado.
The movie comprises an interconnected series
of scenes that offer a glimpse into depravity,
demoralization, and the depths of poverty
— with a linchpin performance by thirteen
year-old Jacob Reynolds as Solomon, a kid
whose hobbies include taking cats, huffing
glue, and paying a developmentally disabled
girl to have relations with him.
Most critics panned Gummo for its pervasive
graphic content, but it was lauded by a few
filmmakers, including famed director Werner
Herzog —who particularly liked this scene
featuring Solomon chowing down on junk food
in a bathtub.
Sue Lyon and Dominique Swain, Lolita
The premise of Vladimir Nabokov's classic
novel about a middle-aged man's  obsession
with an adolescent girl makes it tough to
adapt for the screen — especially when it
comes to casting the title character.
But that hasn't stopped directors from trying.
In 1962, Stanley Kubrick did a more oblique
take on the material, with James Mason as
Humbert Humbert and Sue Lyon as Lolita.
At fourteen, Lyon was two years older than
her character, and Kubrick was careful to
skirt the  content of Nabokov's novel.
"Have you told her anything about us?"
"No, have you?"
But the film and Lyon's role in it still proved
controversial.
And this is one topic that hasn't become less
of a hot potato with the passage of time:
when director Adrian Lyne made his own Lolita
more than thirty years later, with 15-year-old
Dominique Swain in the title role, the movie
was forced to premiere on cable when it couldn't
find an American distributor — and critics
in England even tried to get the film banned.
The entire cast of Kids
This film centers on the lives of several
teenagers — and their lives — during
the height of the AIDS epidemic, and it doesn't
shy away from showing teenagers in some seriously
disturbing situations.
The characters in Kids engage in a lot of
risky behaviors, from doing drugs to having
unprotected with folks, and
the cast was made up entirely of teenagers,
which made for plenty of controversy when
the film premiered with an NC-17 rating.
All these years later, it's still a polarizing
work of art.
Brooke Shields, Pretty Baby and The Blue Lagoon
As a girl, actress Brooke Shields appeared
in two different movies that placed her front-and-center
in the debate about children and on-screen
stuff.
At age 12, she starred in Pretty Baby as a
child prostitute living with her mother in
a New Orleans brothel at the turn of the 20th
century.
The film — and Shields'  in it — was
criticized by many, and the movie was even
banned in two Canadian provinces.
"Well you certainly did it, didn't you?"
However, the backlash didn't put the actress
off controversial material; just two years
later, Shields appeared in The Blue Lagoon
as a shipwrecked girl growing up on an island
with only her cousin, played Christopher Atkins,
for company.
As they reach puberty, they eventually fall
in love, and even have a child — a plot
point which raised eyebrows, as did several
scenes involving the fourteen year-old
Shields.
Linda Blair, The Exorcist
Widely recognized as one of the greatest horror
movies of the 20th century, The Exorcist was
also extremely controversial, with famed critic
Roger Ebert even suggesting it deserved an
"X" rating instead of the "R" it was given
by the MPAA — even though he loved it.
That's partly because of its horrifying subject
matter, but the presence of an actual thirteen
year-old girl in the role of the possessed
Regan MacNeil was also considered problematic.
Linda Blair's performance was central to some
of the most disturbing, disgusting, obscene,
and vulgar sequences in the film, although
she pushed back against rumors that being
in the movie had psychologically scarred her.
She explained: "A lot of untruthful stories
were made up about me being mentally disturbed
by the movie.
I never was because I never bought into the
whole Devil thing."
Instead, it was the physical demands of The
Exorcist that had a prolonged impact; Blair
fractured her spine while filming this levitation
scene, an injury that would later develop
into scoliosis and cause the actress ongoing
health problems well into adulthood.
Tatum O'Neal, Paper Moon
This 1973 comedy-drama is a lot more tame
than some of the other entries on this list,
but it definitely has its moments — like
this one, where its nine year-old star casually
enjoys a cigarette before bedtime.
Tatum O'Neal and real-life father, Ryan O'Neal,
play characters named Addie and Mose, a pair
of unlikely partners in crime on a cross-country
road trip.
Throughout the film, we watch the absolutely
tiny Tatum smoke, drink, and con people out
of their money like an old pro.
And when Mose starts to neglect Addie in favor
of an "exotic dancer" named Trixie, played
by Madeline Kahn, the jealous girl even devises
her own con to get Trixie dumped.
The movie might have been more controversial
if Tatum hadn't been so talented in the role;
her performance earned widespread acclaim,
and she ultimately won an Academy Award for
the part, making her the youngest competitive
Oscar winner in history.
Chloe Moretz: Kick-Ass
At the age of 11, Moretz landed her most controversial
role: vigilante superhero Hit-Girl in the
2010 movie Kick-Ass.
Compared to most little girls — and also
to most grown men and women — Hit-Girl is
a hardened and nihilistic figure, punctuating
her frequent murders with obscenity-laden
one-liners.
Kick-Ass met with backlash for its violence
and language, with many critics especially
horrified by Moretz's character, and it received
a well-deserved "R" rating from the MPAA...
which meant that its most hardcore tween-aged
hero wasn't able to watch herself drop f-bombs
in Kick-Ass without adult supervision.
"Ohhhhkay, geez!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!